les policiers ne sont pas au bout de
leur surprise la suite du témoignage de
Keller va leur glacer le sang alors
qu'il le soupçonne d'avoir commis si
sous cette meurtre l'homme va révéler un
nombre beaucoup plus important de crimes
alors lui il dit j'en ai fait 150 j'en
ai fait au moins 150 qui dit aux flics
pendant la guerre de la vue entendre un
chiffre comme ça on se dit non
certainement vraisemblablement c'est
n'importe quoi c'est sorti comme ça dans
un couloir et pourtant
Ivan Keller l'affirme il pourra apporter
de très nombreuses précisions prouvant
sa culpabilité
7 mars 1991 à Sausheim un petit village
de la banlieue de Mulhouse
le printemps n'est pas encore arrivé en
Alsace il fait très froid
au numéro 17 de la grande rue dans cette
maison imposante vive deux sœurs
comme chaque soir Hélène 83 ans aide sa
sœur Alice 88 ans qui est invalide à se
coucher
[Musique]
puis Hélène montre en joindre sa chambre
situé à l'étage supérieur
[Musique]
la nuit se passe tranquillement jusqu'à
ce que vers 4h du matin
celle de 83 ans entendu bruit dans la
chambre de sa sœur elle se lève
on voit rien de spécial elle va voir sa
sœur
et elle tombe les années sur un
cambrioleur qui
s'enfuit à ce moment-là
hélène est sous le choc son premier
réflexe descendre voir si sa sœur va
bien
elle trouvait les allongée apparemment
endormi
mais en s'approchant elle constate que
sa sœur ne dort pas
elle constate que sa soeur respire plus
apparemment semble mort quoi donc elle a
appelé directement les secours
et ceux qui arrivent
les pompiers se constate le décès selon
les premières constatations la vieille
dame n'a pas résisté aux chocs il est
vrai qu'elle suivait un traitement lourd
pour des problèmes de cœur il s'agit que
la sœur elle est morte d'une crise
cardiaque bon probablement elle est
morte de peur à en voyant le cambrioleur
des suspicions qui seront confirmées dès
le lendemain par le médecin
motif de la mort
arrêt cardiaque
une enquête de gendarmerie est ouverte
et l'on découvre un fait troublant les
sœurs mulaires avaient déjà été victimes
d'un cambriolage un an plus tôt et à
l'époque on leur avait volé beaucoup
d'argent à l'époque on avait parlé de
200000 plus tard en disant il y avait
300000 francs donc l'équivalent de 35000
euros
également donc est-ce que le même voleur
est revenu un an pratiquement 11 mois
après ça on n'a jamais su seulement
cette fois-ci le cambrioleur n'a même
pas dérobé d'argent d'ailleurs on
retrouvera 600 francs sous l'oreiller
d'Alice
les gendarmes vont donc classer
l'affaire et pour tout le monde la mort
d'Alice Muller et le résultat d'un
cambriolage qui a mal tourné
[Musique]
le problème c'est que la liste des
personnes âgées trouvant la mort dans
les mêmes conditions ne va cesser de
s'allonger dans la région et il ne
s'agit en rien d'une coïncidence
crois-moi plus tard à 5 km de là à
Mulhouse dans la rue de bansenheim au
rez-de-chaussée de cette immeuble vide
Yvette gobfert une retraité de 76 ans la
vieille dame n'a plus beaucoup de
familles seulement son petit neveu
Jean-Marie Bechler et sa soeur à qui
elle a l'habitude de rendre visite dans
sa maison de retraite
tous les jours elle partait quand elle
pouvait et partait voir sa soeur
donc elle partait il quand elle quand
elle avait fini
sa visite est rentrée et elle
téléphonait tout de suite à sa sœur pour
lui dire écoute je suis rentré tout
s'est bien passé
chose étrange depuis sa dernière visite
Yvette Gobert ne donne plus de nouvelles
et ne répond plus au téléphone
inquiète sa soeur prévient les secours
mais aussi Jean-Marie Besler qui se rend
sur place
j'arrive il y avait déjà les pompiers
avec gyrophare et tout j'ouvre la porte
les pompiers se précipitent dans la
maison
en pénétrant dans sa chambre il trouve
Yvette goberte allongé elle a l'air
endormie
seulement ce n'est qu'une apparence
quelques secondes après ils sont
ressortis en disant c'est trop tard il
était dans son lit a priori morte Yvette
goberte semble être décédé pendant son
sommeil
vraiment elle avait peut-être pas le ce
qu'on dit le visage apaisé mais disons
elle avait elle était pas anxieuse on
voyait que c'était un visage normal qui
s'est endormi quoi
le médecin confirme le sentiment de
Jean-Marie Bechler et signe la vie de
décès on peut dire arrêt cardiaque mort
naturelle
les Bechler remarquent tout de même
plusieurs détails qui les intriguent
dans la maison d'Yvette gobferte
a commencé par le lit dans lequel elle
est décédée
en soulevant les draps ils font une
étrange découverte
il s'agit d'une tâche de sang à
l'emplacement du bassin de la vieille
dame
bonjour Marie Besler cela ne fait aucun
doute cette tâche est forcément liée à
la mort de sa grande tante c'est une
personne quand même très coquette
toujours bien bien habillé ça il y a pas
de problème d'ailleurs dans le quartier
on l'a appelé la princesse et puis une
maniaque donc ça m'étonnerait que
elle sera couchée dans un lit taché et
cette tache de sang n'est pas le seul
élément étrange concernant la mort
d'Yvette gobferte il y a aussi un volet
qui n'est pas tout à fait fermé
mais surtout Jean-Marie beechler se
souvient que lorsqu'il est entré avec
les pompiers il n'a pas eu besoin
d'ouvrir toutes les serrures de la porte
d'entrée contrairement à d'habitude
je me rappelle toujours que quand on y
allait il fallait donc prévenir et puis
on mettait un temps pour qu'elle ouvre
toutes ses serrures parce qu'il y avait
trois verrous
3 verrous plus pour la serrure normale
malgré ces bizarres Jean-Marie Bechler
ne s'inquiète pas d'abord parce qu'à
l'intérieur de la maison tout semble
être dans l'ordre
il y a pas quelque chose qui a été
déplacé
ou s'il manquait quelque chose il y
avait il y avait pas de tiroirs de
sortie et puis surtout les proches
d'Yvette golferte on fait confiance au
médecin légiste
c'est un légistre vous dit comme quoi
les morts de mots naturels donc c'est
qu'il a rien trouvé il y a pas de coup
de couteau et pas des tremblements plus
personne n'a cherché à comprendre
pour eux la vieille dame a connu la plus
belle des morts en douceur dans son
sommeil
au moment de lui rendre un dernier
hommage quelques jours plus tard dans le
cimetière de la commune personne ne se
doute qui va être goberte a été victime
de l'homme qui a également tué Alice
Muller
11 mars 1994 3 ans après les morts
d'Alice Muller et d'Yvette gobferte le
petit village de Burnhaupt-le-Haut situé
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
Mulhouse est en deuil
[Musique]
Ernestine mangue une retraité de 86 ans
vient d'être retrouvé morte dans son lit
[Musique]
elle habitait dans cette maison au 12 de
la rue Basse c'est le médecin du village
qui est venu ausculter le corps
[Musique]
et il me relève aucun aucune trace
suspecte aucun aucun autre symptôme donc
il délivre certificat de décès quoi mais
la famille de la retraité émet des
doutes quant à la mort de la vieille
dame
ses proches ont en effet constaté des
choses étranges des objets de la maison
ont été déplacés c'est le cas de cette
baratte à beurre qui se trouvait
habituellement à la cave un objet bien
trop lourd pour être déplacé par la
vieille dame
on a également trouvé cette boîte en
bois complètement vide une boîte dans
laquelle Ernestine mangue conservait
quelques économies sans oublier une
bague qui selon la famille aurait
disparu
on parle de on parle de cambriolage
à demeur très de meurtre et de
cambriolage de pas retrouver cet argent
ne pas trouver la bague pour eux c'était
forcément
ça ne pouvait pas être moins naturelle
et forcément quelqu'un avait
pénétré dans la maison et avait commis
un cambriolage la famille
d'ernestinement mise beaucoup sur
l'autopsie pour en savoir plus
pourtant le médecin conclut à une mort
naturelle causée par un arrêt cardiaque
quelques jours plus tard la vieille dame
est enterrée et pour les gendarmes si
ces vols ont bien eu lieu il ne s'agit
que d'une triste coïncidence
mais est-ce que le vol a eu lieu avant
ou après ou on ne sait pas donc
aucune enquête n'a priori n'est
enclenché quand la mort est naturelle
quoi contre toute attente le diagnostic
du médecin ne va pas rassurer les
proches d'ernestinement en effet chose
étonnante
Ernestine est la deuxième femme âgée a
décédé d'un arrêt cardiaque dans la même
rue en quelques semaines
le 21 janvier dernier à seulement deux
maisons de là au 10 de la rhubasse Marie
winterrowler 79 ans a trouvé la mort
dans les mêmes circonstances
sans se poser de questions le médecin du
village avait signé son certificat de
décès
et la série noire ne va pas s'arrêter là
27 avril 1994 un mois et demi seulement
après la disparition d'ernestinement on
apprend que la mort a de nouveau frappé
dans la rue Basse de burna cette fois la
défendre s'appelle Augustave hassmer
elle avait 77 ans et elle résidait au
numéro 22 de la rue cette fois plus
personne ne croit au hasard
ça commence à éveiller un petit peu les
interrogations c'est un petit village
trois grands-mères coup sur coup ça fait
quand même beaucoup
le premier à émettre des doutes sur la
mort d'augustave à SMER s'appelle
Nicolas roclin le petit-fils de la
vieille dame
pour lui cela ne fait aucun doute sa
grand-mère était en pleine forme
elle faisait ses courses elle-même elle
vivait en totale autonomie elle
s'occupait du 3e âge en tant que
trésorière veut dire c'était quelqu'un
de de vivant quoi et qui qui était pas
qui qui était pas sous le coup de la
maladie et ce qui est avéré cette fois
c'est qu'il y a bien eu un cambriolage
chez Augustave hassmer là il y avait
quand même beaucoup de vols et puis un
vol important et puis aussi quelques
la position du corps comme on dit en
effet chose troublante Augusta Wassmer a
été retrouvé allongée dans son lit
exactement dans la même position que les
deux premières mortes de la rhubasse sur
le dos les bras allongés le long du
corps le drap remonté jusqu'au visage
l'infini arrive sur les lieux
force un peu le passage pour voir le
corps de ma grand-mère
et
donc arrive dans la chambre et dit voilà
ma mère elle était allongée par elle si
vous voulez c'est comme si j'avais été
arrangé c'est comme s'il était dans une
chambre mortuaire quoi de se dire que
elle était recouverte proprement des
draps jusqu'au cou enfin comme c'est
endormi d'une belle mort alors que bon
on a quand même le la nuit on a quand
même un sommeil plus ou moins agité donc
là le doute le doute il est là quoi des
doutes même le médecin du village
commence à en avoir d'ailleurs
contrairement aux deux autres défuntes
de la rhubasse il refuse de signer le
certificat de décès
les gendarmes lancent alors une enquête
et se rendre compte que la carte bleue
d'augustave hasmer a été dérobé trois
retraits ont même été effectués dès le
lendemain distributeur soigneusement
choisis parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
caméra qu'on avait pas pu remonter pour
savoir si qui avait effectivement
effectivement ça va être alors qui a
volé cette carte bleue pour les forces
de l'ordre puisqu'il n'y a aucune trace
de cambriolage le suspect pourrait se
trouver dans la propre famille d'Augusta
wa SMER
pour les gendarmes un suspect s'impose
tout particulièrement Nicolas roquelin
le petit-fils de la vieille dame ils
vont alors l'interroger pour savoir ce
qu'il a fait le jour des retraits
bancaires sans l'avertir qui les
soupçonné s'explique pas trop ce que les
gens d'armures est-ce que vous savez
servir d'une carte que je vais manger
enfin ils m'ont fait poireauter là
pendant un quart d'heure pour l'heure le
raconte des serres mais souvenais plus
bon bref et c'est à la relecture de mon
de mon audition que là ça me fait t-il
quoi mais j'ai dit mais il pensait que
c'était nous quoi il y a des il y a des
gens qui qui pensent ah bah tiens c'est
peut-être lui qui a pris l'argent en
arrivant parce qu'il était le premier
sur les lieux il est quand même facile
de de récupérer une somme qui est cachée
dans un tiroir pour récupérer les
papiers de la défunte donc les gens
peuvent se servir
finalement la gendarmerie parvient à
recueillir le témoignage d'un passant la
personne qui a retiré l'argent avec la
carte d'augustave hazmer serait un homme
d'un maître 70 châtain clair et mince un
signalement qui permet aux enquêteurs
d'innocenter Nicolas roclin mais pas de
retrouver le coupable alors une autopsie
est ordonnée sur le corps d'augustave
hassmer quelques jours plus tard les
résultats tombent et pour tout le monde
c'est la surprise
le topif concluait à une mort naturelle
une axe fixie de jurasses fixie mais bon
à la fixie est-ce que la personne
sait tout fait elle-même
face à une mort naturelle et sans aucun
élément concernant le vol de la carte
bleue les gendarmes abandonnent
l'enquête les proches des victimes garde
un goût d'inachevé
musique qui sonne faux quand il y a
quelque chose qui va pas quoi
Augusta va se maire est inhumé
les années passent les doutes
s'estompent
personne n'imagine que pendant ce temps
un tueur continue de commettre des
crimes en toute impunité
c'est finalement le crime quasiment
parfait comme si rien ne s'était passé
il faudra attendre 10 ans avant que la
ferme ne soit relancée
24 juin 2003 brigade criminels de
Mulhouse
ce jour-là un homme insiste pour être
entendu parler enquêteurs il s'appelle
Pierre Keller et il vient avec un but en
tête un peu étonnant
il veut dénoncer son propre frère c'est
denimaçon le chef d'abreuide qu'il
reçoit
et là quelle heure lui fait des
des déclarations mettant en compte son
frère Yvan à en croire Pierre Keller son
frère serait un cambrioleur
un témoignage intéressant mais des
dénonciations les policiers en reçoivent
très régulièrement et la plupart du
temps elles sont mensongères par acquis
de conscience ils vont tout de même
s'intéresser à l'individu en question
Yvan Keller un petit voleur qui a déjà
eu affaire à la police ce fameux Yvan
Keller c'est finalement aux yeux de la
justice un voleur quelqu'un qui a
l'habitude de de pénétrer chez les chez
les particuliers et de les détrousser il
est dans la catégorie des cambrioleurs
quoi de de
sans plus
Yvan Keller n'est qu'un petit truand
mais il est tout de même passé par la
case prison à cause d'un cambriolage qui
a mal tourné c'était en 1982 et à
l'époque il avait passé cette année
derrière les barreaux
elle a été brutale c'était des coups
violents il y a eu du sang la
séquestration de d'une femme et des
enfants les policiers se rendent compte
que depuis sa sortie de prison il y a
près de 15 ans Yvan Keller n'a plus fait
parler de lui
seulement son frère va aller plus loin
dans ses accusations à l'en croire
Ivan Keller n'est pas seulement un
cambrioleur mais aussi un meurtrier
et lui dit que c'est un cambrioleur
que c'est une personne non seulement qui
convoitole mais qui tue les personnes
chez qui il cambriole
il s'agit en général de personnes âgées
et
il fait passer ces meurtres pour des
morts naturels les policiers sont
obligés de prendre au sérieux une telle
dénonciation
il pousse alors leurs investigations
survivant Keller mais là encore rien à
signaler l'homme semble être devenu un
modèle de réinsertion
d'après sa boîte de
paysagiste c'est une toute petite
entreprise donc ce sont des travaux
d'élagage
taille de haie quelques plantations
d'arbres voilà un bon alsacien qui est
un entrepreneur quelqu'un de plutôt
sympathique très gentil très poli pas un
mot plus haut que l'autre
méticuleux soigneux et toujours souriant
Ivan Keller semble être très apprécié
par ses clients
le cas de Madame Kaiser
charmant il était agréable
était toujours là à l'heure faisait du
très très bon travail il était très très
professionnel il connaissait très bien
son travail pour Denis maçon l'enquêteur
ce faisceau d'information donne surtout
l'impression d'une histoire de vengeance
entre frère
il y avait des tensions dans la famille
et aussi peut-être des affaires de haut
des affaires Patrick clairs entre eux
aussi
si il n’obtient pas de nouvelles
informations le policier le sait il
laissera tomber cette dénonciation mais
c'est sans compter sur un coup du hasard
15 jours plus tard le 7 juillet 2003
dans son bureau de la brigade criminelle
de Mulhouse le policier d'animation est
sur le point de chlore le dossier Yvan
Keller
mais en évoquant son nom par hasard avec
un collègue il apprend quelque chose d'à
peine croyable Yvan Keller a déjà été
dénoncé c'était il y a plus de 10 ans et
à l'époque l'information ne provenait
pas du frère de Keller mais d'un certain
François de Nicolo
difficile de croire à une coïncidence
avec une on pouvait se dire que c'était
un mythomane comment savoir un deuxième
même si effectivement là aussi les
enquêteurs connaissaient très bien le
pedigre de Pierre Keller ils se disent
que il y a quand même quelque chose qui
colle pas quoi
ce nouveau témoignage relance l'enquête
à sa tête le capitaine Gilles Poirier de
la police judiciaire de Mulhouse
Poirier va se replonger dans le
témoignage de Nicolo et voici ce que ce
dernier avec confié aux forces de
l'ordre il y a 10 ans
je lui servais de chauffeur je
l'attendais plusieurs heures dans la
nuit et je le déposais à plus d'un
kilomètre de là où il voulait aller il
me donnait 500 francs ou 1000 francs de
dédommagement mais je ne savais pas ce
qu'il faisait
mais un jour l'un des cambriolages
auquel participent de Nicolas va prendre
une tournure tragique
donne à une enquêteur l'adresse d'une
voisine de sa maman en lui indiquant que
ce voisin donne régulièrement des
bonbons un peu d'argent à ses enfants
et que vraisemblablement elle doit
disposer d'argent de bien chez elle à la
maison et puis de jours après ben la mer
était la voisine de la mer était
retrouvée morte chez elle et du frigo
disparu cette mort étrange ne sera pas
la seule quelques jours plus tard de
Nicolo accompagne Yvan Keller sur un
autre cambriolage il ne rentre toujours
pas dans la maison et le lendemain
François de Nicolo apprend que cette
personne était également décédée qu'à ce
moment-là il comprend que Yvan Keller
fait bien plus que des cambriolages
qu'il a peur en disant pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est-ce que je vais être mouillé
dans ce crime avec Keller
mais pourquoi ce témoignage n'a-t-il pas
été pris en compte par les gendarmes il
y a 10 ans sans doute à cause de la
personnalité trouble de François de
Nicolo un indique de la police loin
d'être toujours crédible donne des trucs
enflés une fois il les dit pas une fois
il dit il est Mythos il raconte plein de
trucs aussi au bout d'un moment les
enquêteurs sont dit voilà c'est un peu
c'est un peu le mythomane de service
mais cette fois c'est différent le
témoignage de Pierre Keller le frère
d'Yvan confirme les dires de Nicolo
Gilles Poirier n'a plus le choix il doit
enquêter sur des morts remontant parfois
à 15 ans un véritable travail de fourmi
[Musique]
on cherche quoi des personnes décédées à
la maison
déclarer morte naturelle
des on recherche des faits de
cambriolage cocomutants à ces morts
naturels il s'agit de personnes âgées
les témoins souvent sont soit loin ou
décédés puisque bon on va on recherche
quand même sur une période de 10-15 ans
15 ans
donc
très long travail et la première étape
pour l'enquêteur sera d'interroger de
nouveaux François de Nicolo
le capitaine Poirier convoque l'ex
complice de Keller cette fois il va
exiger de lui beaucoup plus de détails
il va retourner sur les lieux avec ce
témoin il va le faire parler il va faire
ressortir les dossiers il va
effectivement se rendre compte qu'il y a
des dossiers qui ont été classés de
Nicolo donne des adresses précises
correspondant à des morts suspectes 5 au
total toutes situées dans la région de
Mulhouse
après enquête trois de ces adresses
répondent aux critères de recherche des
enquêteurs
[Musique]
des personnes décédées à domicile il y a
eu des vols
et
voilà et parmi les dossiers dans
lesquels se replongent les enquêteurs il
y a les trois mortes de la rue Basse à
Burnhaupt-le-Haut
à la lumière des nouvelles informations
certains éléments anciens prennent une
autre dimension a commencé par le vol de
la carte bleue d'augustave hassmer à
l'époque le signalement effectué par un
témoin n'avait permis aucune
identification cela pourrait maintenant
changer ce témoin décrit finalement d'un
homme un mètre 70 châtain clair et ce
signalement correspond notamment à tel
est arrivant Gilles Poirier son équipe
retrouve vite la trace de leur homme
mais pour l'heure il est hors de
question de l'interpeller il faut dire
que les policiers ne disposent d'aucune
preuve
c'est sûr que si nous on vient avec peu
d'éléments
il va il va nourrir au nez il va il va
nous dire mais moi j'ai rien fait déjà
en 2000 on va déjà dit des choses mais
moi on n'a rien pu prouver puis moi je
fais rien moi pour découvrir si qu'elle
est l'homme qu'il recherche les
policiers vont alors déployer de très
gros moyens naturellement tous les
moyens techniques possibles et légaux
ont été utilisés donc ça soit les
surveillances interception de
conversation téléphonique
pose de de d'enregistrement sur les
véhicules naturellement
durant plusieurs mois les enquêteurs
épiles et moindres faits et gestes du
suspect mais le résultat s'avère
particulièrement décevant et les
policiers ne disposent toujours d'aucune
preuve sur des meurtres éventuels
en revanche les filatures leur ont
permis de découvrir quelque chose de
très intéressant le train de vie de
Keller et de sa compagne semble modeste
mais ce n'est qu'une apparence
dans sa vie normale il est il est peu
dépensier c'est-à-dire que il n'a pas de
véhicule de luxe
bon il a un appart il ou un appartement
loyer correct
mais une feuille paillasse pas des
dépenses somptueuses à part les dépenses
de course de chevaux
les dépenses aussi de casino et les
voyages de ils prennent des suites à 500
600 700 euros la nuit bon un moment on
apprend qu'il veut qu'ils veulent passer
un week-end
à Paris donc l'hôtel pareil c'est un
hôtel de luxe
pour un simple paysagiste quoi
ces éléments aiguisent les soupçons de
la police comment le couple peut-il
dépenser des sommes aussi importantes où
trouve-t-il l'argent alors que les
revenus de Keller dépassent à peine le
SMIC
l'argent pourrait faire figure de
mobiles solides pour la police il n'y a
plus de doute Yvan Keller a parfaitement
pu tuer les vieilles dames dans la
région et voici quel était son mode
opératoire
tout d'abord son métier de jardinier lui
permettait de repérer à l'avance les
femmes âgées et seules
il va donc repérer ces personnes seules
il va
identifier un moyen de rentrer donc les
les suivre être attentifs à leur mode de
vie aux personnes qui leur rendent
visite
à leur solitude et puis il va
s'introduire par tel ou tel moyen soit
en escaladant parce qu'on savait que
c'était un grand escaladeur vous savez
que son métier c'est quand même de
monter dans les arbres
soit par les fractions la plus camouflée
possible
après cette introduit dans les maisons
Keller aurait procédé à des vols
relativement discrets avant de tuer ses
victimes
[Musique]
là encore le plus discrètement possible
un arrêt cardiaque peut être provoqué
par un par exemple avec l'aide d'un
oreille on étouffe les gens
et si elles se sont débattues s'il y a
eu une petite bagarre ou quelque chose
qui a pu se passer il va avoir
l'intelligence de refaire le lit de
reborder les draps il va réorganiser
cette scène de crime pour qu'elle
paraissent paisible à tout le monde y
compris à des spécialistes comme les
médecins comme s'il était morte
calmement de sa belle-mort voilà ça
c'est les paramètres
qui nous disent qu'elle air travail
comme ça problème si Gilles Poirier est
convaincu de ce qu'il avance il ne
dispose d'aucune preuve matérielle
en tout cas pour le moment
[Musique]
septembre 2006 dans la région de
Mulhouse une recrudescence de
cambriolages est constaté c'est la
police judiciaire qui est saisie de la
faire
rapidement les policiers interpellent
plusieurs suspects et parmi eux un homme
attire leur attention il s'agit d'Yves
après trois ans d'investigation les
enquêteurs viennent enfin de trouver le
prétexte idéal pour l'interroger
Keller ne va pas se méfier car forcément
pour lui l'interrogatoire ne portera que
sur de simples cambriolages
on va interpeller
Keller sa compagne ainsi que différents
membres de sa famille ou d'anciens
complices ou de personnes dont les noms
étaient retrouvés pendant l'enquête ils
vont aller voir vraiment toute la
famille Keller
y compris interpeller toute la famille
qu'elle est donc
on fait pas ça si on n'a pas l'idée
qu'on a peut-être un gros coup qu'on
peut sortir quelle air est donc placé en
garde à vue avec d'autres suspects dans
les locaux de la police judiciaire de
Mulhouse et son attitude va surprendre
les policiers
il a un petit peu étonné sa compagne de
même mais je veux dire aucune question
comme si c'était normal qu'on fasse
notre travail pierre Peter l'avocat
commis d'office de Keller ne s'est pas
non plus que son client est soupçonné de
meurtre pour lui aussi il s'agit d'une
simple histoire de cambriolage les
policiers lorsqu'ils nous accueillent
nous disent de quoi il s'agit donc on me
parle cambriolage mais j'en sais pas
plus lui il me dit rien donc je lui
explique ce que c'est qu'une garde à vue
quels sont ses droits et je lui dis que
s'il le souhaite je peux revenir le voir
demain voilà ça s'arrête là
très rapidement on lui dit
qu'il est là pour des vols
des vols
ou des victimes ont pu les victimes de
vol ont pu mourir parce que
parce qu'il fallait les tuer
quelle heure
non seulement ni les vols mais ni
naturellement à avoir à un moment ou un
autre tu es quelqu'un le premier
interrogatoire s'achève donc sur un
échec
mais quelques minutes plus tard lorsque
débute la deuxième audition les
policiers décident d'abattre leur carte
il confronte Yvan Keller au dénonciation
de François de Nicolo et de celle de son
propre frère mais là encore Yvan Keller
ni en bloc si ce genre raconte ça il
m'envole ou je comprends pas ils ont
peut-être fait des choses et puis ils
mettent ça sur mon dos c'est c'est donc
voilà la deuxième audition comment ça se
passe toujours pareil mais les heures
passent et Yvan Keller commence à se
sentir pris au piège il n'avait pas
prévu une telle épreuve d'autant que ses
proches sont également interrogés
le seul moyen à mon avis pour les
policiers de faire avouer ils vont
Keller c'est effectivement de lui dire
bah regarde toutes les personnes qui
sont en cellule à côté de toi en garde à
vue toutes ces personnes l'attaquentent
maintenant il faut te mettre à table la
tactique des policiers est simple faire
durer l'interrogatoire le plus longtemps
possible pour faire craquer le suspect
et le pousser aux aveux
il faut quand même savoir que là les
enquêteurs travaillent sur sur du 96
heures de garde à vue on a
cambriolage bande organisément
association de malfaiteurs donc on peut
on peut faire durer une garde à vue 4
jours quoi étoffée par la pression des
enquêteurs fatigués Keller change de
comportement
et un moment
en tant que puisque je suis son
interlocuteur privilégié c'est moi qui
l'entends
là je le vois qui qui fait un arrêt il
fait un arrêt et d'écouter
bon j'ai compris quoi
je vais vous parler
mais il me dit je vais vous parler mais
là il prend un peu le temps parce que là
on voit que c'est c'est pas une petite
affaire quoi je veux dire
j'ai deux demandes à faire
avant de parler Keller fait la liste de
ses exigences des exigences pour le
moins surprenantes
premièrement je voudrais que ma
concubine soit un petit peu protégée
c'est-à-dire dans le sens où je voudrais
qu'elle soit pas embêtée par sur deux
gens soit immédiats ou d'autres
personnes donc qu'elles soient un petit
peu
éloignée de Mulhouse quoi et
deuxièmement en prison je voudrais être
à l'isolement les policiers prennent
note des demandes de Keller mais à
présent pour l'urgence et de le faire
parler et voici ce que l'homme va leur
raconter
dans un premier temps il dit oui
effectivement j'ai commis des
de nombreux cambriolages
alors avec
soit des complices ou seuls mais bon je
vous prie et j'ai endormi des gens
quelle air aurait endormi ces vieilles
dames en clair il les aurait tué
pourquoi j'ai endormis les gens pas
parce que
tout simplement parce que je savais
qu'il y avait de l'argent parce que moi
je sais quand il y a une maison je pense
qu'il y a de l'argent je il faut que tu
restes à certains temps pour arriver à
trouver cet argent quand je vois que la
personne se réveille où je vais être
dérangé ou cap pourra me reconnaître
donc là
ça peut pas rester comme ça donc là je
prends un chiffon
n'importe quoi
et là je l'endors je l'endors c'est à
dire que ben c'est dire que ben voilà je
suis enlève l'air et puis je voilà
elle est morte
à présent les enquêteurs ont la preuve
qu'ils avaient vu juste et que Keller
était bien responsable des morts
étranges sur lesquels ils ont enquêté
et Yvan Keller à vous sans problème
qu'il a effectivement tué Yvette
gobferte ainsi que les trois autres
dames de burn-up le haut l'homme
n'évoque pas Alice Muller l'une des deux
sœurs de Sausheim retrouvez morte lors
d'un cambriolage mais pour le capitaine
Poirier tous les éléments coïncides
les policiers ne sont pas au bout de
leur surprise la suite du témoignage de
Keller va leur glacer le sang alors
qu'il le soupçonne d'avoir commis 6 ou 7
meurtre l'homme va révéler un nombre
beaucoup plus important de crimes alors
lui il dit j'en ai fait 150 un effet au
moins 150 qui dit aux flics pendant la
guerre de la vue au niveau régional au
niveau national et au niveau
international puisque l'Allemagne et la
Suisse sont cités comme des terrains de
travail de Keller entendre un chiffre
comme ça on se dit non certainement
vraisemblablement c'est n'importe quoi
c'est sorti comme ça dans un couloir et
pourtant
Ivan Keller l'affirme il pourra apporter
de très nombreuses précisions prouvant
sa culpabilité il faut simplement qu'il
rassemble maintenant ses souvenirs il
faudra que j'ai des cartes routières
qu'on puisse se déplacer ensemble et là
je vous montrerai pas de problème je
vous montrerai et puis bon ça reviendra
parce que là c'est un petit peu bon
naturellement quand vous avez comme ils
disaient avoir commis tant de fées je
pense qu'il faut mettre un peu d'ordre
mais il est tard qu'elle est fatigué à
bout de nerf il veut tout arrêter
c'est vidé quoi il s'est vidé et donc il
me dit ben écoutez maintenant on arrête
la garde à vue est terminée Yvan Keller
va passer la nuit au commissariat dès le
lendemain c'est face au juge qu'il se
présentera mais personne ne se doute que
cette affaire va très vite connaître un
coup de théâtre sans précédent
22 septembre 2006 le palais de justice
de Mulhouse est en ébullition Yvan
Keller attend d'être présenté au juge
avant la comparution il passe quelques
instants avec son avocat on est dans le
couloir tous les deux et pendant une
heure et demie il me raconte un peu sa
vie ce qu'il a fait et puis surtout il
me demande la même chose que la veille
il me demande d'intervenir pour protéger
sa compagne ça c'est son son idée
essentielle elle ne sait rien il faut
qu'elle soit en dehors de tout cela vers
11h les deux hommes pénètrent dans le
bureau du juge Matthieu Bonduelle
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois que
celui-ci accepte de s'exprimer à propos
de la faire Keller
quand il rentre dans mon bureau il est
plutôt vif il est même très vif il est
pas du tout prostré il a pas l'air
épuisé pas du tout il a envie de tout de
suite de me dire des choses
sur un accord qui l'aurait passé avec
les policiers pendant sa garde à vue
mais on n'a pas encore accompli les
premières formalités donc je lui dis
attendez on va d'abord vérifier votre
identité je vais vous annoncer quelle
est la qualification qui pour l'instant
est retenue contre vous et ensuite on y
viendra donc il comprend très bien
on ouvre le procès-verbal il accepte de
répondre aux questions
Ivan Keller et disposé à collaborer et
immédiatement il réitère les aveux
effectués la veille en garde à vue
reconnaissez-vous l'effet qui vous sont
reprochés oui
je l'invite à revenir sur des points sur
lesquels je m'interroge notamment sur
son mode opératoire et il y revient donc
assez en détail que faisiez-vous quand
les gens se réveillent
au début je me contentais de partir
c'est plus tard qu'il y a eu des
problèmes plus tard quand les gens se
réveillaient et qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'argent je les endormais en leur
mettant un chiffon dans la bouche et on
leur pinçant le nez
il expliquait qu'au début il passait le
nez de ses victimes et il mettait un
chiffon dans la bouche pour les étouffer
ensuite il expliquait qu'il s'était
rendu compte que ça pouvait laisser des
traces
un peu après je laissais de nouveau un
peu d'air je veux dire que la personne
pouvait parter comme ça doucement et
après j'appuyé en fin de compte
presque on va dire naturellement comme
les certificat de c'est le mec le juge
c'est désormais précisément comment ils
vont Keller ses victimes mais une énigme
subsiste comment est-ce possible que les
proches des victimes n'est quasiment
jamais remarqué que des objets de valeur
avaient disparu une fois encore c'est
Keller qui va apporter la réponse
vont pas tout de suite voir si ou
découvrir qu'il y a eu vol ou
pénétration dans les lieux ne vont pas
remarquer qu'il manque un objet ou qui
ne manque de l'argent ils vont pas le
remarquer tout de suite sous le choc
elles vont pas avoir l'impression que
quelque chose à bouger et s'ils sont
aperçoivent c'est par la suite et puis
ils sont ils sont quand même pris par le
décès de leur grand-mère ou de leur
tente donc ils ont autre chose à
s'occuper que de vérifier c'est pas eu
un quand il lâche surtout que le médecin
a dit que la mort était naturel dans le
bureau du juge tout le monde est
abassourdi devant de tels aveux
Ivan Keller lui parle avec une certaine
assurance
il sent bien qu'il est l'objet de toutes
les attentions voilà ça se sent dans son
attitude
sans dire qu'il a un comportement de
divin mais on sent quand même que
c'est lui le personnage important de
cette séquence mais au beau milieu de sa
déposition Yvan Keller s'arrête et pour
aller plus loin il exige cette fois que
le juge lui donne des garanties sur les
deux demandes qu'il a formulé la veille
sa mise à l'isolement des tensions et la
protection de sa compagne quand
avez-vous commencé à agir de la sorte ça
je ne vous le dirai pas aujourd'hui je
serai plus précis quand ma copine
Séverine sera relogée en dehors de
Mulhouse je veux aussi qu'on lui procure
un travail c'est le contrat que j'ai
passé avec les policiers en fait il me
le dit pas simplement pour me le
rapporter il me le dit pour que je
valide cet accord je dis c'est je dis
que j'apprends ce qui s'est dit
là-dessus en garde à vue ça n'apparaît
nulle part dans les procès-verbaux lors
des comptes-rendus téléphoniques on ne
m'a jamais parlé de ça et même devant
l’interrogatoire je vous dis on me parle
de quelque chose mais qui est différent
c'est à dire qu'il a des revendications
mais on ne parle pas d'un accord et là
le juge d'instruction lui avait dit je
peux pas m'en occuper tout de suite mais
je ferai nécessaire etc en revanche je
l'avertis en lui disant légalement là je
n'ai pas de texte à ma disposition qui
me permet de faire droit à vos demandes
et je m'étonne que les policiers et puis
vous dire que ça à cet instant il vend
Keller comprend l'ambiguïté des
promesses faites par les policiers
a-t-il l'impression de s'être fait avoir
aussitôt le ton monte il exige une
réponse
cette réponse rapide il n'a pas eu donc
il s'est dit ça y est je suis coincé en
fin de compte en fin de compte ce qui
m'a promis il m'a rien dit mais moi je
suis je suis pas un Chérif je suis pas
un cowboy je vais pas négocier avec lui
des choses lui menti pour finalement me
le mettre dans la poche et qu'ensuite il
dit tout ce que j'ai envie d'entendre
pendant l'instruction pour Yvan Keller
c'est la fin de l'entretien et il décide
de ne plus collaborer
là il se met un peu en colère et il
m'indique qu'il ne veut plus signer le
procès-verbal
Yvan Keller est aussitôt reconduit dans
les cellules du palais de justice avant
une nouvelle comparution l'après-midi
même
jugé policier sont frustrés il ne
disposent pas Davos signes et divan
Keller celui qui pourrait être le plus
grand tueur en série française de tous
les temps les magistrats décident de
partir déjeuner il compte sur cette pose
pour permettre à quel air de se calmer
seulement une négligence de l'Escort qui
accompagne le suspect va avoir des
conséquences dramatiques
il est 13h30 et c'est aussi l'heure du
déjeuner pour Yvan Keller
l'homme attend dans une cellule du
palais de justice
il y a trois cellules
une au fond
là où on met les gens qui le gardent lui
demandent s'il veut manger un bout
effectivement il dit oui oui
une pizza donc il reçoit une pizza les
policiers de l'Escort
eux ils disent ben on le laisse
tranquille laisse manger une demi-heure
plus tard les policiers reviennent
chercher Keller dans sa cellule et il ne
s'attendent pas à ce qu'ils vont trouver
vers 14h on le retrouve pendu au crochet
du néon ça cellule avec c'est la section
c'est un retournement de situation
incroyable les enquêteurs et le juge
sont sous le choc
en moins de 48 heures ils ont vu
apparaître le plus grand criminel de
leur carrière et tout aussi rapidement
l'homme a disparu
on était effondré on était effondré à la
fois pour des raisons humaines parce que
moi je venais quand même de lui parler
pendant une heure et demie donc je peux
vous dire que maintenant ça a été un
choc très important et en plus c'était
une enquête sur lesquelles les policiers
avaient énormément travaillé cette fois
Ivan Keller a définitivement échappé à
la justice peut-être avait-il prévu de
longues dates qu'en cas d'arrestation il
ferait tout pour éviter la détention
[Musique]
il y a de la détermination dans ce dans
ce morceau
il m'a laissé entendre qu'il ne ferait
pas de détention et peut-être d'ailleurs
me suis dit après est-ce pour cela qu'il
voulait être à l'isolement pour être
seul pour être seul et peut-être pouvoir
se suicider sans que un code détenu
éventuellement le secours et comme c'est
plus lui qui menait la danse et ben il
s'est dit voilà vous n'aurez jamais rien
[Musique]
Yvan Keller est mort et pourtant
l'enquête ne s'arrête pas loin de là
[Musique]
le tribunal de Mulhouse a sans doute
identifié un des plus grands tueurs en
série française
Ivan Keller 46 ans à avoir une trentaine
de meurtres de vieilles dames avant de
se suicider les vérifications sont en
cours le lendemain du suicide d'Yvan
Keller l'annonce de sa mort fait l'effet
d'une bombe la presse s'intéresse à
l'affaire et refait l'enquête les
journalistes retrouvent Pierre Keller le
frère d'Yvan qu'il avait dénoncé en 2003
il a été victime d'un accident depuis
mais il n'a pas perdu sa verve
il a tué des clients à lui personne
âgées
[Musique]
humains
deux questions restent en suspens Yvan
Keller avait-il des complices et surtout
à combien s'élève le nombre de ses
victimes
il avait avoué des dizaines de meurtres
avant de se suicider et bien les
enquêteurs ont acquis la certitude qu'il
est bien à l'origine de 8 d'entre eux en
quête Lionel fuyerstein Zidane vercus
jour après jour la justice découvre
l'immense parcours criminel divan Keller
les enquêteurs de Mulhouse ont déjà
identifié formellement 8 victimes sur la
trentaine de meurtres travaux en Alsace
certaines personnes font aussi tôt le
lien entre ces reportages et le décès
d'une personne âgée survenue dans leur
famille c'est le cas de Nicolas roquelin
le petit-fils d'augustave Wasmer l'une
des trois vieilles dames retrouvées
mortes dans la rue Basse à Burnhaupt il
n'avait jamais arrêté de s'interroger
sur la mort de sa grand-mère et c'est en
lisant cet article dans le journal qu'il
comprend qu'elle a bien été assassinée
je relis l'article maintes et maintes
fois j'essaie de bien tout comprendre
et pour moi là on y est quoi
là maintenant je suis sûr
là où beaucoup de personnes m'avaient
dit bon Nicolas là il faut peut-être un
petit peu il faut peut-être un petit peu
arrêter
ça devient sa devient du quotidien tu te
materas la tête
et là on y arrive quoi là on est
[Musique]
l'explication mais surtout ce qu'on a du
mal à comprendre c'est déjà premièrement
le fait de l'apprendre par le journal de
pas avoir été averti avant
incompréhension mais également colère en
effet la mort divan Keller coupe court à
tout espoir de procès en plus on apprend
qu'ils se suicidé
en juge qui
comment savoir combien de meurtres
qu'elle air a-t-il commis 150 comme il
l'a dit moins de 10 comme le pensait les
enquêteurs avant de l'arrêter le travail
de recherche de victime est colossale
ça c'est un travail de fourmi qui est
encore plus encore plus fastidieux
encore plus compliqué que le travail
antérieur je dirais à l'ouverture de
l'information judiciaire on a une un
objectif qui est très clair qui est de
faire la lumière sur tous ces homicides
reconnus avouer par Yvan Keller pour
accélérer les démarches le juge Bonduel
décide d'utiliser un moyen plutôt
inhabituel il va convoquer les caméras
devant l'ampleur du dossier le juge
d'instruction a décidé de lancer un
appel à témoin il s'agit donc de fait
qu'il se déroulerait dans des maisons
particulières dans lesquels des
personnes âgées seraient décédées on a
retrouvé où on aurait retrouvé ces
personnes soit dans leur vie soit près
de leur lit dans une attitude qui peut
correspondre à un décès naturel dès le
lendemain les retombées de ce message
télévisuel seront énormes elles vont
démontrer que les victimes divan Keller
étaient bien plus nombreuses que ce que
les enquêteurs n'avaient imaginé
en fait les policiers ont été submergés
ont reçu énormément de témoignages et
ensuite il s'agissait de les vérifier
c'est à dire faire un travail de
vérification d'enquête classique
c'est-à-dire aller vérifier l'existence
même de ce décès s'il y avait eu une
enquête ou pas au moment du lycée et
donc si oui va récupérer les
procès-verbaux de cette enquête pour
faire toute la lumière et essayer de de
voir si ça pouvait coller comme on dit
ou pas avec les crimes reconnus avoués
par par Yvan Keller des vérifications
les enquêteurs en effectuent dans de
nombreux villages près de Mulhouse mais
les suspicions de crimes imputables à
quelle heure vont largement dépasser les
frontières alsaciennes c'était quelqu'un
qui était un flambeur qui bougeait qui
faisait les casinos qui avait le tour de
l'Europe et on sait qu'il a pu utiliser
ces techniques en cas de besoin quand il
avait besoin de liquidité dans d'autres
pays on sait qu'en tous les cas il
existe des dossiers en Allemagne et en
Suisse en Suisse c'est une certitude et
donc on a beaucoup de difficultés à
établir la liste de ses victimes
également en Europe après quatre ans
d'investigation sur l'un des dossiers
les plus complexes qui a eu à traiter la
justice française plusieurs dizaines de
meurtres seraient déjà attribués à Yvan
Keller aujourd'hui on est on a réussi à
plus ou moins montrer qui vont Keller
avec tué plus d'une trentaine de
personnes le chiffre exact
vraisemblablement 34 35 mais on continue
encore un petit peu à chercher et on
pourrait on pourrait en avoir d'autres
mais le nombre de victimes n'est pas la
seule inconnue de l'affaire une autre
question reste en suspens à part de
Nicolo quelle est avait-il des complices
c'est la grande question pour l'instant
on n'a pas de réponse comment pouvait-il
maîtriser ses victimes
puisqu'il ne pouvait pas les tuer tout
de suite puisqu'il fallait les faire
parler avant comment pouvait-il
maîtriser ses victimes seul tout en
fouillant leur maison
les empêcher de crier les empêcher de se
sauver certaines étaient quand même
suffisamment valides pour se sauver
il semble qu'il manque quelque chose
dans le descriptif des scènes de crime
d'autres personnes étaient au courant le
frère d'abord puisque au fond
c'est par lui que qu'on va l'apprendre
mais il le savait depuis longtemps
sa femme peut-être en tout cas elle dit
non mais elle a bénéficié du fruit de de
ces
de ces crimes et puis finalement ça
devient une certitude absolue lorsqu'on
examine ses aveux parce que dans ces
aveux lui il va dire qu'il n'a pas agi
seul des journalistes vont retrouver la
trace d'une des anciennes compagnes
d'Yvan Keller au début des années 90
devant la caméra celle-ci va faire un
témoignage édifiant
des complices qui ont pu tuer avec Yvan
Keller mais peut-être aussi sans lui
nous ce qui nous inquiète le plus c'est
de savoir si c'est complice à un moment
donné trouvant la technique intéressante
non pas eux-mêmes repris le flambeau et
agissent seul il laisse en tendance et
aveux que ça peut être le cas et là ça
devient terricher parce qu'on peut se
retrouver devant une liste de victimes
un vrai semblable aujourd'hui l'enquête
sur d'éventuelles complices de Keller
continu une procédure qui ne parvient
pourtant pas à calmer la colère des
familles de victimes qui ne comprennent
toujours pas comment
Ivan Keller a pu agir sans être inquiété
pendant près de 15 ans
[Musique]
c'est quand même un fruit après de se
dire ma grand-mère est morte pour 3000
francs
j'en fais quoi les gens là
les aveux divan Keller auraient pu faire
de lui le plus grand tueur en série
français de tous les temps mais son
témoignage demeure à ce jour un
vérifiable
mort avant d'être jugé aux yeux de la
loi française Yvan Keller reste présumé
innocent
[Musique]